hey my name is Samuel leaves and in this
video I'm gonna explain to you how you
can buy your dream home for free no
money down dream home yes it's possible
firstly let me just say a bit of
background context to this most
landlords are financially insane they're
crazy
my landlords I mean I'm a tenant myself
I rent where I live and I rent out what
I own and that's a smart way
commercially to do it most lenders are
crazy like honestly I rent these houses
I pay such a little rent and the
Landlord buy them and place so much I
don't know how they make their money I
really don't like I'm moving at the
moment I'm just moving house and I'm
looking at a property and it's worth 4
million pounds that's how much it's
worth 4 million pounds
the landlord paid about two and a half
million for it he's renting it he's
gonna be renting it to me for 11 and a
half thousand pounds a month it's like
four million pounds for in seven and a
half thousand pound rent like the return
on investment for that is insane I don't
get it I was I was looking around some
houses some nice big houses I would
stand outside some but it'll be a bit
awkward I might get some funny looks
these houses are quite nice these are
probably worth about a million pounds
but I've been looking around some super
expensive houses and and there was this
one house the landlord he put furniture
in it he told me that the furniture was
worth a million pounds I'm thinking why
on earth would you furnish a house and
spend a million pounds I don't ever even
if I believe him or not but the
furniture was nice it was like all
Russia and it's what apparently the
President of Russia uses and I said I
said to him I said why would you do that
and he said because this is my biggest
asset and in my mind I'm thinking it's
not your biggest asset if you're
spending a million pounds on furniture
like the amount that's going to push my
rent up is so small it's gonna cost you
a fortune when you're buying a house
it's all about what you put in as little
as possible get back as much as possible
so while I was viewing these houses and
came across some opportunities
multi-million pound houses to buy them
for free and a spa
with the landlord's I spoke with the
agents and I just thought a hat to share
this I cannot share how to do this
hopefully some of you guys running to
buying some houses so where you live
some beautiful houses for free so I'll
give you the figures to this particular
house that I saw absolute mansion add
nine bedrooms the most amazing house you
could see it looked like The Fresh
Prince of bel-air
you know Will Smith's house incredible
house
it was owned for rent for 10,000 pounds
a month which seemed okay
quite expensive but I guess it was a
nice house it was on the market for sale
for three million pounds so on sale for
three million
rent for ten thousand pounds a month
this owner had bought the house they
live in America that invested in the UK
they'd bought the land they'd built the
house from scratch to sell it it had
been foot on for sale for 4 million
hadn't sold they dropped it down to
three and a half hadn't sold they've now
dropped it to three it's been on for six
months at 3 million it's not selling why
is he not selling probably because
people are a bit unsure at the moment
the house is near London so we've brexit
and stuff people are just thinking let's
see what happens so houses aren't
selling that easy those kind of mansions
on selling that easy
it's they've just put it on rent for ten
thousand pounds a month I see it I'm
like looks nice I'm moving towards
London anyway let's let's check it out
look round it it's on for ten thousand
pounds a month I said to the agent I
said you know I noticed it's also on for
sale what's going on he told me the
story he said it is on for rent he said
however the owner would be open to so I
like a rent to buy type setup I'm
thinking hello sounds like a lease
option agreement which is how I buy a
lot of my houses so I said how would
that work if we did like rent to buy and
he said well you could pay the rent he
said as long as you could move red to
move quickly you could pay the rent and
then maybe that could come off come off
of the other of the purchase price so
let me just get this right now by the
way just for the record I didn't do the
deal because the house wasn't right for
me but let's say it was my dream home
let's get this right if the owner were
prepared for me to pay 10
thousand pounds a month for say five
years and then in five years
buy it for three million but the ten
thousand pounds that I've been paying
each month is gonna come off of the
asking price this is where I need my
calculator right now are we doing what
sir Jay yeah things are fine yeah okay
cool I'm happy this is where I need my
calculator right here so five years is
60 months 60 months times 10,000 it's
easy calculation 600,000 pounds so I can
move into this house pay 10,000 pounds a
month which is what the rent is anyway
but you'd have to pay that anyway just
to rent it just to be a 10 but that's
called dead money right it's okay if you
want to spend 10,000 it's dead money but
I'm paying 10,000 a month for five years
but then I have the option to buy it for
three million which is about what it's
worth today anyway I know it's not
selling because the times a bit tricky
but three million in five years now
here's the cool thing in five years it's
probably gonna be worth a lot more than
three million why because houses go up
over time and London's a bit a bit skip
a bit stick right now and London's a bit
sticky right now but we know that that
will change in a year or two so so okay
so I've got a bargain at the end of it
but even better than that the 10,000
pounds that I've been putting the size
that equals six hundred thousand pounds
six hundred thousand pounds is 20% of
the purchase price for three million so
what dishes potentially thinking
creatively a dream come true now for
someone that wanted to live in that
dream house so you move in you pay ten
thousand a month you could ask after
five years that the owner give you back
all that rent for you then to just buy
the house they give you back six hundred
thousand and then boom you put that down
to deposit on the house you buy the
house no money down now I didn't do this
deal okay so some of you might be
thinking you know yeah it sounds good in
theory I've done this on much smaller
houses I've done it loads but you could
do this and
you could buy your dream home now
legally speaking here's my advice don't
think of all the reasons why it won't
work don't think or but what about this
all but what about that although I need
to speak too much no here's how business
works this is how business works you
understand and a third party come up
with a win-win situation the vendors
happy the sellers happy you're happy
then you go to a solicitor and you say
make it happen that's how business works
now you also don't have to do this with
your dream home necessarily or your
dream home might not be 3 million some
of these houses around here they're just
a million you could do the same sort of
setup you could buy it for a million in
five years and pay a thousand pounds a
month which comes off the asking price
now I'm not suggesting that you
necessarily do this with a three million
pound house and paid ten thousand pound
a month rent you could just take a zero
off you could do with a house that's
three hundred thousand and pay a
thousand Panamint rent but the point is
when you think creatively you don't have
to wait you have to wait 20 years to
save up to live the life you want you
can live the life you want now as long
as you're creative so what's the
ultimate lessons ultimate essence are
think abundantly be creative take
massive action you can make it happen
out of this video I have a funny feeling
because it always happens when I do
videos like this the stories happen
people go dude stuff think creative
maybe you're a tenant now and you love
the property and you can wring your
current landlord strike a deal I don't
know but if a story comes out of this
video I want you to find me find me on
social media tell me the story I'd love
to know why because your stories in your
success and my oxygen so keep it going
subscribe keep watching and I hope to
see you on the other side
[Music]